our subject for this evening
will a man rob god what did i say
now don't let your mind go off in the
obvious direction you may be disappointed
it is will a man rob god the three
favors i always ask one wherever possible
use a bible instead of a phone so bibles
turned on and phones turn off wherever possible
favor number two while i'm speaking pray for me
and say lord put your words in that man's mouth
that is based on what bible verse jeremiah
chapter one verse nine what does it say
then the lord put forth his hand and
touch my mouth and the lord said unto me
behold i have put my words in thy mouth and
favor number three i want you to think well
god wants you to think not just i and that's
based on isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together as i've said before god is
a reasonable god and he calls us to reason
and in that act of reasoning honestly the spirit
of god will cast light into our minds our subject
will a man rob god let us pray loving father
in heaven we ask in the name of jesus christ
to come very close to us father as we listen to
your word as the word is spoken their god we need
our spiritual faculties activated and so we
ask your father teach us through your spirit
touch our hearts their father that we may obey
what we learn if the others on their way bring
them safely we ask bless all our friends
via the internet their god touch them also
with truth their father and soften their hearts
that they may accept the truth that they hear
their god thanks for the freedom of worship in
this country thank you lord for the access we have
to you through christ now we commit this service
to you take all the glory their god but give to us
the blessings because we need them in jesus name
we pray amen genesis chapter one let's read from
verse one our subject will a man rob god exactly
seven thirty genesis one reading from verse one
do you have that read with me in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth go to verse
2 and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters verse 3 and god said
let there be light stop stop stop it's okay
god bless you for your eagerness and god said
let there be light that's the word of god let
there be light i repeat that is the word of god
and so the bible tells us in psalm 33 verse 6
by the word of the lord where the heavens made
we read in hebrews 11 3 through faith we
understand that the worlds were framed
by the word of god and so when you read let there
be light that is the all-powerful divine living
spirit-filled word of god now we go from
the word to and there was light what is that
we have the word let there be light then
we have there was light what is that
okay the the the the expression of the creative
power of god's word or you may say leslie be light
that's the word there was light that's
the miracle produced by the word
let there be a firmament and it was we have the
word we have the miraculous outworking of the word
all through genesis 1 the word the miracle
the word the miracle it was a miracle for
god to say let there be light and the light
just appeared that was a miracle of miracles
now let's go to hebrews 11 verse 6. our
subject will a man rob god hebrews 11 verse 6.
it's a well-known verse i know you can say
it without looking but i'll let you find
it nonetheless hebrews 11 verse 6. do you have
that we're reading from the king james version
read with me but without faith it is impossible to
please or to please him for he that cometh to god
must believe that he is and that he is the
rewarder of them that diligently seek him
let's read the verse again read it again what is
it saying but without faith it is impossible to
please him yes without faith now go to romans
7 romans 10 sorry verse 17 romans 10 another
well-known verse verse 17. you'll observe night
after night we use the principle of line upon line
precept upon precept hear a little very little
that's the way to study the bible any other method
will lead to error romans 10 verse 17 when you
found it say amen read with me what does this say
so then faith cometh by hearing and hearing
by the word of god so we have the connection
between faith and god's word it is impossible to
have faith without expressing that in god's word
faith is total trust in the word of god to do
what it says let me say it again faith is total
commitment of the self to the claims of god's
word and that's based on the fact because the
word says let there be light and there was light
you see that's the word that's a miracle the very
first chapter of genesis and i've said it before
faith is total trust in that word that created
heaven and earth now the bible says someone who
does not believe god's word cannot please god
without faith it is impossible to
please god for he that cometh unto him
or unto god must believe that he is he is
first and that he's a rewarder of them that
diligently seek him he is he is a god of
his word let me say it again god is a god
of his word if we have difficulty swallowing
that it is because we are not people of our word
despite the best of intentions we may have
we are not naturally people of our word god
is a god of his word and we say one more
time but without faith it is impossible
to please him now jesus lived
by faith in the word of god
let's go to john chapter 8 we'll read verse
29. and then we'll go to first kings 17
john 8 verse 29 listen to the testimony
of jesus christ the gospel of john
fourth book of the new testament written
by the closest disciple to christ and he
lived the longest what other books
did you write revelation first john
ii john and third john john 8 29 the words of
christ read with me and he that have sent me
is with me the father hath not left me alone
why for i do always those things that please
him now read the verse microscopically i do always
those things that please him we read in hebrews 11
6 without faith it is what impossible to please
god then if jesus only did what pleased god what
kind of life did jesus live a life of faith but
faith in what faith in the word of his father
jesus believed his father's word in his
humanity he trusted he leaned his weight
on the father's word no wonder on the cross
when he was forsaken and there was darkness
the disciples had run away he said into thy
hand i command my spirit he trusted his father
because christ has studied the gospels he knew
that there was a prophecy that will not leave
this my soul in hell nor suffer thy servant
to see corruption he had known that despite
the discouraging circumstances he trusted
his father's word when everything was dark
it is easy to trust god when
you have all the money you need
it's another thing altogether to
trust god when you have the tithe
and your bills are not paid now let's go to
psalm 115 we read verse 3. psalm 115 or verse 2
and verse 3 of psalm 115 our subject is what
will a man rob god psalm 115 verses 2 and 3.
before we read that let me just tell you a
story that you know in first kings 18 elijah
is in a contest with the priests of baal
those who had dinner all the time with
jezebel there was a total actually
of 850 priests on that mountaintop
up against elijah one man a priest of god a
servant of god up against 850 false prophets
and they set up their altar
and they cried all day to bail
and no answer came uh elijah made fun
of them i think in verse 27 and he said
shout a little louder maybe he is uh talking
or maybe he's pursuing a journey or maybe he
is somewhere or perhaps he's swedish and he needs
to be awakened and so their god demonstrated no
power we so elijah was where's your god where's
your god but sometimes the heathen ask us that
go to psalm 115 now let's read verse two and
verse three our subject will a man rob god
a little prayer just before we read father
continue to be with me in the person of your
spirit of truth i pray please in jesus name amen
where thou should wherefore should the heathen say
where is now their god now this is the heathen
talking about the israelites where's their god
they're in trouble they're defeated by
their enemies they're suffering perhaps
there's a famine there's a flood there's a
plague where is the god of the israelites
and so the bible says why should the heathen
be in a position to say where is now their god
and i wonder sometimes do other churches
say where is the god of the adventists
they broke just like us they sick just like
us homes are broken up just like us
children are wives just like ours yeah the
young people in the casinos or
the the nightclubs just like ours
they pursue education just like us the
hospitals look like ours where is their god
where is their god that's the question
where is now they got verse 3 says
but our god is in heaven he hath done whatsoever
he have please really if our god is in heaven
meaning he's in control there ought to be
some evidence of that seen in his people
let me say differently a people among whom no
miracles are worked is a people that embarrass
us their god because the god looks weak the
god looks helpless and the reason why god
looks helpless is because we don't trust god you
see god does not reward doubt god rewards faith
let me show you what i mean first king 17 let's
read from verse one our subject will a man
rob god first kings 17 we'll read from verse one
do you have that
we're introduced to brother elijah
now elijah's he just pops up all of a sudden
out of nowhere on the pages of the bible
and elijah the tishbite who was
of the inhabitants of gilead
said unto ahab as the lord god of israel liveth
before whom i stand there shall not be due nor
rain these years but according to my word elijah
told ahab there will be a famine in this land
where there's no rain there are no crops where
there are no crops there's no food where there's
no food there's famine there's suffering there's
all kinds of hardships elijah says there will not
be dew nor rain these years but according to my
word and the word of the lord came unto him saying
get thee hence and turn the eastward and hide
thyself by the cherished that is before jordan
and it shall be that thou shalt drink of the
brook and i have commanded the ravens to feed
thee there now god tells elijah go a certain
place this famine all over i will take care
of you elijah goes where god sends him by
the way don't go away god doesn't send you
sometimes on the radio on television
people call themselves prophets
and uh prophets are people who are not are
called not volunteered you don't volunteer to
be a prophet you may volunteer for the pathfinders
or for the deacons but you don't volunteer to be
a prophet you don't offer yourself here i am do
you need my services god as a prophet a prophet
is ham picked by god now he can reject that call
which is a serious thing but you don't volunteer
to be a prophet i was in a certain african
country there were prophets all over the place
all over the place god called elijah god sent
elijah don't go where god has not many times
people say come and speak for me and i s for
us and i say well pray to god and get some
conviction that he wants me because he has
seven thousand others who have not bowed the
deed to bail god has servants all over the place
pray and ask god do should we invite this man
if your conviction is strong and you call me then
i'm going with the confidence that god has sent
me are you following me but i don't want to go
where god has not sent me answer elijah's by
the cave or in the cave by the brook the ravens
feed him morning and evening every day until god
moved him to another location now verse 7 says and
it came to pass after a while that the brook dried
up because there had been no rain in the land
and the word of the lord came at him saying arise
get into zarephath which belongs to zidon and
dwell there now read with me now pick it up
and behold i have commanded a word of women
that with widow woman there to sustain thee keep
reading so he walked he arose and he went where to
zaraphath and when he came to the gate of the city
behold the widow woman was there gathering of
sticks and he called to her and said to her what
fetch me i pray thee a little water in a picture
that i may drink now this is there's no rain
you understand so you know the water supplies
had dried up elijah is thirsty he travels some
distance as she was going to fetch it he
called to her and said bring me i pray thee
a morsel of bread in thy hand so he wants a
little glass of water and a piece of bread
clearly this man is hungry he's a servant
of god hardships do not escape god's people
one of the mistakes a lot of people
make when they come to christ they expel
all their problems cease no problems no hardships
no trials no no when you come to christ the devil
goes into high gear to make sure that you're so
troubled that you may be discouraged hardships
come the way of god's people but we know where our
what's the expression where our bread is buttered
it may only be bread and water but it's sure
can you say amen and so elijah said fetch me
some water bring me a morsel of bread and she
said what did she say as the lord thy god liveth
i have not a cake but a handful of meal come
on in a barrel and a little oil in a cruise
and behold i'm gathering two sticks that i may
go in and what dressed it for me and my son
that we may eat it and die what was that
meal called what would you call that meal
last meal i don't want to say last supper but last
meal are you following me this is the last time
we leave then we lie down quietly and we die
now this is real there was a terrible famine
because you read chapter 18 ahab and his servant
called obadiah they went all to the country
looking for grass for the cows and the horses and
the mules it was rough so this woman wasn't joking
when she said i'm going to dress it for me and
for my son that he'll need a little cake alit won
then we will die because we have no
flour left we have no oil left after this
elijah said unto her fear not
go and do as thou has said
now read with me but make me thereof
a little cake first keep reading and
bring it unto me keep reading after
make for thee and for thy son stop
those words came from where god
the word of a prophet must be the
word of god are you following me
or that prophet is just making noise the
word of a prophet must be the word of god
so god spoke to that lady through
elijah give the first cake to god
and as much as he done it unto one of the
least my brethren you've done it unto me
give it to elijah give it to
god then take care of yourself
now she could have disobeyed
she could have disobeyed
we are as human beings we're very skilled
at giving god reasons why we should not obey
i was a in a certain country conducting a revival
staying in a little hotel in and out there was a
security guard at the gate would open the gate let
us in and out the sabbath morning we were driving
out we told him why don't you come to the meetings
he said i'm a 70 adventist so the driver of my car
the car was in he said why are you working on
zabal he said i have no choice i have a family
now to the eye of the average person or to the
ear of the average person that is a compelling
argument i have no choice i have a family
listen carefully i don't mean to sound unfeeling
coarse or harsh there are no acceptable
reasons to god for disobedience
none so he said i have a family
i have no choice but to disobey
that woman could have said what my last
handful of flour and my last few drops of oil
make a cake for you a man i've never seen
and ignore my little boy i can't go without not my
son parents will die to keep their children alive
but she did as elijah said for
thus saith the lord god of israel
the flower the barrel of meal shall not waste
neither shall the cruse of oil fail till the
day that the lord sendeth rain upon the earth and
she went and did according to the saying of elijah
and she read verse 15 with me and she and
he and her household did eat many days now
why does that miracle occur because she
obeyed the word of god if she had disobeyed
she would not have seen the miracle and she
would have robbed god of an opportunity to
display his power is that clear now you see
why i chose the title she would have robbed
god every act of disobedience is robbing god of
an opportunity to display himself in our lives
or in a circumstance and so here's a young person
just graduated from college the degree still has
the the the the order of freshness on
it looking for a job eighty thousand
dollars or perhaps a hundred thousand in
debt every job offer requires sabbath work
a person has to set up a family set up a bank
account have little savings look forward to
marriage one or two children all of that
is going to the mind of the young person
but every offer requires sabbath work
and the person is assessing the evidence
that person can case in and decide let me
work on sabbath until i establish myself
then i will stop all the work may require
work on sabbath once every six months
just once
surely someone will argue come on don't be
an extremist it's just once every six months
i
i was talking to a young person
who was a working for a bank and the bank put
pressure on that person to work on sabbath
once in a while and that person absolutely refused
the parents said what's the problem the parents
are adventists work it's not every sabbath it's
once a month sometimes once every six weeks work
and that young person was distressed
and depressed that her seventhly
adventist parents in the interest of economic
security would try to encourage sabbath work
and i said don't work
then came dismissal from the
job what should i do don't work
six weeks later a new job came much better than
the last one with the highest salary somebody say
amen obedience allows god to demonstrate his power
every time we disobey we rob god of an opportunity
to perform a miracle to display his power to show
his love for us disobedience is robbery and my
question is the question of the bible will a man
rob god will you and i rob god by disobedience
one of the hardest people in the
bible who was ever converted was
he'll be nebuchadnezzar the kingdom when
you see him don't be shocked he will be
in the kingdom we know what happened in daniel
chapter 3 the boys were threatened with death by
fire if they did not bow let's go to verse 15
of daniel 3 as we continue will a man rob god
daniel 3 reading from verse 15.
you have that
now if you be ready that at what time you
hear the sound of the cornet flute harp sac
but soldier and dulcimer on all kinds of music he
fall down and worship the image which i have made
well but if you worship not he shall be cast
the same hour into the midst of a burning fiery
furnace and who is that god shall deliver you out
of my hand who is that god what can he do for you
now when when somebody says who is your god to
an obedient person god will show that person
who he is you know what pharaoh said who
is the lord that i should obey his voice
and let israel go exodus five verse two when moses
and aaron said let my people go he said who is
god that i shall let the israelites go and then
god showed him who he was and he didn't like it
now nebuchadnezzar says who is that god they shall
deliver you out of my hand now by obedience to god
god had an opportunity to
show nebuchadnezzar who he was
as when three boys maintained
their fidelity to god
their refusal to violate commandments one
and two they were tossed into the fire
now let's read verse 28 of daniel 3 28 of daniel
3 do you have that read with me what does this say
read nice and clear verse 28 even as us spake and
said what blessed be the god of shadrach come on
meshach and the better go stop what did he say
blessed be the god his attitude towards god now
is changing blessed be the god are people
impressed by the god of seventh-day adventists
based on how we function he didn't say blessed
to be the god of babylon of blessed be the god
of shadrach meshach and abednego keep reading who
have sent his angel and delivered his servants
they trusted in him and uh-huh the king's word
and yielded their bodies that they might not serve
not worship any god except their own god
nebuchadnezzar says blessed be the god
of shadrach meshach and abednego
question for you if they had bowed
would god have had an opportunity to demonstrate
his power no he would have been robbed listen to
me disobedience is robbing god as an opportunity
to show the world who he is and to remind us
read verse 29 nice and clear what does this
say therefore i do what make a decree that
every people nation and language we speak
anything i miss come on against the god of
michigan and better go keep breathing shall
be cut in pieces and there shall be made what
now finish that first because there's no uh-huh
i've never seen a god like this now keep
in mind the babylonians had a lot of gods
chadra was named after god misha and abednego
their names were connected to babylonian gods
nebuchadnezzar said i have there is no
other god that can deliver like this god
and when you're faithful and you refuse
to take that exam on sabbath and the lord
makes the way they must say there's no
god that can make a way like this god
when you refuse to work on sabbath and god sees
you mean it unto death he will perform in such
a way that onlookers will say there is no
other god that can do what this god does
but when we disobey and we yield and we
buckle at the knees god loses the opportunity
to demonstrate his power and his love and his
concern for his people and for the unbeliever
because god wanted to save nebuchadnezzar and
so nebuchadnezzar confessed there is no god
including mine that can deliver after this sword
daniel 6 the same thing daniel was tossed into
the lion's den darius came to the mouth of
the den oh daniel verse 20 is thy god whom
thou serve is continually able to deliver from
the lions is your god able to overpower my gods
dinosaur king live forever read verse 22 now
of daniel 6 my god did what i like that my god
not our god because the god of heaven
and earth was not the god of darius
the god of hanoniyah michel azariah was not the
god of nebuchadnezzar but he became the god of
nebuchadnezzar as a result of the faithfulness
the obedience of those boys and so daniel said
my god have done what sent his angel come
on and i shut the lines about that they
have not hurt me why for as
much as what innocence he was
found in me and also before the o king
have i done nor her daniel said my god
and the king was so impressed with daniel's god he
ordered daniel removed and he threw his own people
who would hatch the plot they were killed by the
lions and darius made it clear that daniel's god
was the god to be respected and admired and
feared why was this miracle because daniel obeyed
commandment one and two thou shalt have no
other gods before me he could not pray to darius
christopher's life was obedient and
god demonstrated his power let me
say it for the 15th time obedience provides a
platform for god to demonstrate what he can do
i have run into so many people in my travels
who can give that testimony of the power of god
in their lives as a result of their
faithfulness to him and my burden tonight
is to call upon us to trust the word of god
you don't need to know greek and hebrew and
aramaic and whatever else to learn the lesson
that god simply requires faith in his word a child
like faith let me give you a well-known example
recite this passage with me without looking
malachi 3 verse 10 bringing all the tithes
into the storehouse how much tithe all the
time that they may be meet in my house and
prove me now here with stop god is just about the
only god that invites his subjects to prove him
now other gods invite the
subjects to prove themselves
show me why i should save you god says no you
can prove me he invites us prove me now here with
saith the lord of hosts if i will not
open you the windows of heaven and pour
you out a blessing that there shall not be room
enough to receive it that is what the word says
now if you believe that when you're
looking at the little money you have
and you look at your bills
and it's time to go to church
you need to put that money in the
envelope where it naturally belongs put it
trust the word because it's the same word that
said what let there be light finish it for me
and there was light the word that says i'll
bless you so you won't have room to receive
it is the same word that said let there be
light and there was light trust god's word
be not overcome of evil finish the verse but
overcome evil with good trust that word it works
someone abuses you do good it works
any system god originally works
what's our subject will a man rob god how
do we rob god disobedience to his word
because when we disobey god
is unable to demonstrate
his power i ask a question don't answer me is
this some area of disobedience in our lives
you know sometimes during church services
it happens at my home church we may call for
testimonies and people say oh the lord wake
me up this morning and everyone says amen
which is true this is true but
every rapist in prison can say that
every wino can say that every prostitute
can say that every atheist can say that
so what's the big thing now i'm glad he woke
you up don't misunderstand me i'm glad he
woke me up but surely the child of god should have
something to say that most other people cannot say
and that will only happen as we obey god
how should we obey god microscopically
whatever he says do it whatever he tells you do
it if god says don't work on sabbath don't work
if he says this whatever he tells you do it
or don't do it as the word of god comes to
us go to john 5 quickly let me show you
some wisdom from the virgin mary herself
one of my favorite verses in the bible
here's some wisdom from the virgin well a pastor
of mine used to say the blessed virgin mary
whenever he spoke to catholic audiences he called
it a blessed which is a very biblical expression
the angel said you're blessed she was a virgin her
name was mary the blessed virgin mary all right
this is the very first miracle christ performed
what was that miracle turning water into wine now
let's read verse three you have
that one more prayer before we go
father as i come to the close stay
with me in the person of your spirit
give me the right words as i close in
jesus name i pray amen read from verse 3
john chapter 2 verse 3 where did i send you oh no
no no no john chapter two the key verse is five
but john chapter two are you there now read with
me what does it say his mother says unto him what
john chapter two verse three three reading from
three to five i said the key versus five but we
read from three now let's read what does it
say on the wine his mother said unto him they
have no wine now they run out of wine at the
wedding that's embarrassing run out of food
wine whatever kool-aid it's embarrassing verse 4
jesus said unto her woman what have i to do with
the my hour is not yet come it's not the time
for me to be doing this but that's his mother
read verse 5 his mother saith unto the
servants whatsoever he says unto you do it
i work that into many sermons i
preach whatsoever he saith unto you
do it when they obeyed what happened a miracle so
we have obedience miracle from genesis 1 obedience
or the word of god miracle of course when god
made light the life is not a human being but
when god gives a command to a person if the person
obeys the outcome will be a demonstration of god's
power in your life you obey the health laws the
miracle will be a change in your health you obey
the financial laws of the bible the miracle
will be a change in your financial condition
whatsoever he says unto you tell me
is that simple yes it is my friends via the
internet my friends in person live that way
what he tells you to do do it and he said
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy do it
don't argue and discuss and negotiate do it
how many of you will say with me father
give me the strength the willingness to do
whatever jesus says can i see your right
hand or anyhow stand up with me give me
the willingness why do we have to ask for that
because obedience to god is not natural behavior
it comes about by the implanting of impulses
that originate with christ let me say it again
obedience to god is not the natural behavior
of a human being here is the natural condition
because the carnal mind is enmity against
god for it is not subject to the law of god
neither indeed can be so when someone
says obey god the person ought to tell you
by the sustaining power of god obedience to god
requires power from god as bowed eyes closed
father in heaven we thank you for your word we
thank you father for the word let there be light
and there was light when that word is spoken
to a human being where the person obeys the
outcome is the miraculous outworking of god in
the person's life father help us to understand
that an act of disobedience robs you of an
opportunity to demonstrate and display your power
you are a god who loves to display your power
you love to demonstrate your ability to take
care of your people father put into
our hearts a hatred for disobedience
and a love for doing whatever you say let us live
by the words of mary to the servants in john 2 5
whatsoever however extreme it may sound
however ridiculous it may sound our human mind
whatsoever he saith do it let this be the way we
live i pray and if there are areas in our lives of
rebellion disobedience that we have reasoned
ourselves into deliver us from that dear god
and let obedience be the theme and the rhythm of
our lives that miracles may also be a part of our
regular life father thank you for being patient
thank you for being long suffering thank you for
being merciful god write your law again tonight on
our hearts that we may obey you with joy naturally
and gladly bless all those who came bless those
listening and watching via the internet their god
let us leave knowing we have heard from you i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen and amen
you